uh let's talk about the canada stuff
first um i think everyone generally is
like this is crazy but there's a couple
of different pieces to unpack the first
being um
i think that there's nuance around the
protest themselves of like i always
think of like if i was trying to live in
a city and a bunch of people came and
just parked their cars and like little
is it gridlock and you couldn't go
anywhere that'd be annoying for the
local residents now there may be a good
reason for doing it or not a good reason
but like i do think that there's an
element of like the people there like
hey this sucks but that's not what's
going on anymore like that was like for
like a day or two and then it seems like
they got cleared out uh pretty quickly
and then it just became like what a
normal protest would be right where
people were like voicing their opinion
but the government like kept pressing
and that to me seems like we're like
okay that's crazy
is that kind of your read on it as well
yeah i mean obviously it's very heavy
it's an ongoing situation and
i've spoken with a couple canadian
friends
and one actually dm me the other day and
they said
they were talking they're living in new
york now but they were talking to some
of their friends that live in ottawa and
they said that their life
didn't really seem all that different a
few weeks ago when the truckers were
there yeah the honking was a bit
annoying but i mean the government said
stop honking and get fined and a lot of
people stopped honking yeah and then
that's funny how that works it was fine
they said like funnily enough like as
soon as they started cracking down the
police did that's when they actually
noticed that there was a disruption in
the city it's like when the police
started doing blockades on the road and
i just think
with the whole situation and the
reaction to it i just i i'm somebody who
just likes logical consistency uh and
consistency uh
with particular situations when you
compare
the reaction by these uh governments to
what happened in the summer of 2020 in
reaction to uh george floyd and that
whole um situation too
what's going on now i just don't think
there's a lot of consistency across the
reactions there was a lot of damage and
um destruction in the summer of 2020 and
we can
have the debate if that's a viable form
of protest or not and then this one up
in ottawa seems very peaceful um you
know you literally have kid bouncy
houses like in the middle of yeah of the
city and that's their form of protest
and
it doesn't seem like
the reaction is really because of a
disruption of everyday life in
ottawa but uh the the fact that they
really don't like what these particular
group of people are are actually
protesting which is civil liberties yeah
one of the things that uh
i'll never forget
uh watching because i don't really watch
like the news right like in terms like
the live news uh but during i think it
was uh the summer of 2020. remember when
uh
the protester i'm gonna use that as a
terminology if i don't know who
what cause what side of the debate
whatever but there was a group of
citizens that basically set the police
department on fire in like minneapolis
or something and like they like got into
the police and i remember watching that
as it was developing just being like
holy like like this is like another
level right it's like okay protest got
it okay even like the
violence or property destruction like in
new york city there was you know
multiple situations where they were
breaking glass or whatever like again
you get drunk people who knows if
they're part of the project like when
you get to the point where you're
literally setting the police department
on fire like that was like okay we we've
breached into a level of this that like
is not going to be well received by most
people right
and again it goes back to like
the
inconsistencies like there's that famous
meme of the cnn reporters like literally
in a gas mask and there's a city on fire
behind him and he's like the the tagline
on cnn is mostly peaceful protest
the media apparatus the political
apparatus back then was
vehemently against or excuse me with the
protesters in that situation and they
are fighting for civil liberties too
um a lot of them i believe at least
thought they were and then here again in
canada it's mostly peaceful and uh it's
it's
people need to get trampled with horses
and put in place like in philly where
i'm from they were ghost riding
cop cars down broad street and
they were blowing up atms and like
taking stuff and there there was nowhere
near the reaction
that the protesters in canada are are
are going through right now but again
two different countries so
um
there's also this part of like uh
um
i think the police and and i want to be
uh
as thoughtful as i can about how to uh
present this idea i have a theory which
is uh
when the
people who are protesting have like
signs they're honking but they're
generally
willing to adhere to the rule of law
the cops actually are emboldened and
they can have like a very very uh kind
of iron-fisted response and they know
these people will basically comply at
some
point right
but what we've seen
in france in the united states uh and
many other places around the world is
that when the
descent
is much more formidable much more
violent et cetera actually a lot of
times what happens is the police
basically they they walk away right they
they back up and like it's almost like
when two strong forces meet the police
are the ones who back away and they
don't become combative usually because
they're outnumbered or whatever uh
and so it's like very interesting
dynamic of like the more peaceful you
are actually in some way it elicits a
stronger response from the police versus
if you're you know setting the city on
fire the cops seem to be a little you
know less excited about going outside i
don't know yeah i mean the violence
begets violence uh type of mentality i
think if you're if you're gonna meet
that violence that was happening in 2020
with with police violence it could have
certainly just poured fuel in that whole
fire i think
again what the what's going on in canada
right now specifically what we should
really hone in on is that is
a
people are fighting for their right to
actually be able to live within an
economy to go to work too it's great to
make make a living put a put a home over
their their families
um and actually feed their families and
the the fact that it's gotten to this
point where
uh you have justin trudeau and their
government enacting the emergencies act
to
um freeze people's bank accounts and put
people on list
uh if they were supporting the truckers
in any way it's pretty frankly scary and
it's even scarier is that there's not
politicians from the united states or
other quote unquote western
free democracies standing up and saying
hey justin want you once you chill out a
bit you're here have we seen anyone
other than the el salvador president i
think he had
some tweets about basically just being
like hey if i was doing this you guys
would be like invading my country right
uh but other than that i don't think
we've seen anyone really no no step up
and i think that's
the silence is deafening and i would
consider it somewhat of an endorsement
of what's going on up there because this
would be real they want to
do this stuff in the united states too i
mean it's pretty clear that they want to
usher us into the central bank digital
currency world the fed's talked about it
ecb's talked about it they want to do it
up in canada the uk
as well and i mean i think
uh majid uh which is on rogan like this
listening to that on the way down i
think the way he
described it was extremely cogent like
they it's the vaccine passports which is
what's being protested in canada are the
trojan horrors you get people showing qr
codes at a restaurant just to go eat and
it starts there but then it's oh you
actually can't eat this burger because
it's deemed too fatty you got to eat the
soy burger instead
and that
apparatus that qr code app uh this sort
of the trojan horse that leads to
that control over over people's lives
and economic freedom hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time